[Music]
[Applause]
and they rush military mieke monday or the
netherlands'
with substations run the world and really
had to be here two
when look around this tedx mcdm from
you guys i am very special needs you a
reason why he  said yes to the
installation to come here
today we to succeed because als-ie people
who want to make a contribution
ac people who want to make ik bij de
world by doing
groundbreaking scientific work by
creating and passive works of art by
lighting I became all  articles already in spanring
books
where it says i have sustainable business
is
annual has xhose your own instruments
to fulfill this mission of creating i
bij de lead sant joan de microscope
best instrument all shows dancing on
painting
remark music hatch with correct sant
josep en everything work
sorry  instrument of money
ladies and gentlemen arm and dave and
joyce
it
read and jon hamm
all share your goals and share the goals
of the speakers your help before a dit not
choose d  e tick have the pen
the brush the camera
machos this instrument
aitches de gone for you and your way
whose so close to this can make you feel
and easy
it feels to me for a moment carey and real dan a
review cycling distance
that's step for a moment
enfield  is a sns iq dear sir red
leather chair is defective
the pore most of you have never been
cloister least
the netherlands is a peaceful country
de nellens is not the beautiful
the least soleus not needed to pro
streets
chance of natsepa the highlights in many
countries
this is a disney story in opinion can
handle countries people because it
lesbians the purchase rest
the carpenter this at warlords
but terrorist at criminals web a
scan dewall of the years chose or much
this dress white and
and my standing before you with this
meppen
why they like you dig en s me
instrument
today i want to tell you why to day and
more to tell you why shows the gone to
create better world and want to tell you
how disco
can he  lp my story starts in the city of
nijmegen in that is the netherlands after all
the city where was afraid
my father was a hardworking cup
when the party how i was in the bakery
that morning tony and my brother stories
and most beautiful the garden
doesn't tickle dis thorium gone  to share
with you know
the story of what having when was i
can pointed cabbage
solio in the so to the force with the
beginning of the second world throw
the nazis in peace the netherlands the
[ __ ] lens we evident
dmn tool by means of repression
diplomacy
het  field to stop the sons
oil blood force belt and this was all
last free kind
my vale was there to provider has a
sanne deform how new wooden hand
my father was an excellent march me
but here at the end
missing it is decisive moment in
dutch history my  father was patient to
the bank of the river waal
new city of nijmegen
here i have leather shot and the german
soldiers who came to lure by every
country
this country our country and fire
no  thing happened if i'm no dennis o'neil
field and the fire my father can enter it
and all the cognitive which the op
possesses river bank
the last shouts much tom and there was
nothing
but varric becomes target beret and counted
day-mar father  running that was frustrated
it maud missing the shots
i could not done something how is a
handling
to even the best maximum amount force
is good huh heat mark zo this story is
always best with ben en highschool
igrip where the stories of the aleid
soleus
soldiers who left  the safety of de roon
rooms and less than life to liberate the
country and the people
women who came to liberate
as from through your anus
the sand ice only god can stand
between good and evil
and that's true but when snapped can wet
the should not to kill
not to this story what the city those who
aim is to project the  from rabo
to that guy  democrat i values
the standing for peace how you do
her also to this dn amsterdam
about how week and meter wilde at the
price
read a gentleman earth not stand
you today
tell you but the glory your weapons he
does not like plans and once
you him  in one the vario itself
this brings han even more clearly that I
then break another macho instrument
mate iceland here today
the tell you but the user the hallway if you have
an instrument of peace and stability
the game may be one of the  most important
instrument of peace and stability that we
have this board
well this is my sound contradictory toe
but not only
see her be my boot during my die
fold mens in the lips and sarajevo
en worst national old dutch
chief of defense
this is also support at  colt
had statistics file and seth
declined with the song about the last 500 here
despite the pictures how the show and
daily in the news bos between developed
countries
but no longer commonplace the motor  drove
an hour on the magazine side effects
of city since the middle ages
and then course of civil war and repression
of declined since that them to control
statistics show we you a living in
a relatively
peaceful and my wife island i knew he
they here might change
but how we have attracted someone young man
this morning
this again simple jealous al beasley
impulse for revenge for violent
rituals for pure race ever the something
health in is suffered is book haven
professor steven pinker
and many other singles who conclude for him
that one of  the people site
the opinion drivers at entre les sailing
society's
is the spread or the constitutional stitch
and that introduction to a large scale or
the increasingly monopoly under song the corn
use of finance the heat meist where you
democrats cli
electr government that you the most  few
checks and balances and independent you
the shell system
in other words
i put my apple iehh that house the use
of violence
does control such  as always
monopoly
to finance first of all sister is a
reshoot
it who had that incentive for a
poor orphan my friend potentially hasta
the blood are our societies
secondly the presence of penalties that
former members benefits of using finance
tips the tube that fulfill
apps training  from finance that comes more
profitable and star hear things well
nam finance is able to work like and
flywheel
this and get them spie 70 euros where is still
conflict
2 colors and 2 is another important
incentives'
grants finance lift know the s mutual
interdependence and mutual game  between
parties and which is my youtube
game both sides
agreed is more than new game
has it
beautiful is simply no longer the best option
and that is why finance
guess the priest
this ladies and gentlemen is rational
bh the existence of my aan force  is that
to force is implement
the increasingly monopoly unsafe hood is en
lodge at the maize two only after old
democracy restart at home to shower  n
it is this lisette with control views of
the gun that has contributed greatly
to using the statistic zo full conflict
and violence
because i run it is this participation
in peacekeeping missions the rest led to
the resolution of many civil wars
my soul jazz use the gun
there are instruments or choose
and this is exactly lee maifeld always on
so theeuwes
many states have no legit the mouse the
clique talk to me unrolls use of force a
lot always do up now of the corridor and
his instrument of peace and stability
that is my lot always
can drag down your region into engels en
conflict
that is why speaking concept of the
constitution still the station
impotent effect of old forum actions
that is why we are trying to built and
you wish i left and right now en
afrikanen stem
that is why we  two police office of the
train judges
week my public prosecutors and let
world and that is why and then an ellen's
how your varys now i have a unique in
that that is we had dutch con  institution
always that one of the main bags of the
armed forces
is to uphold and promotes the international
roelof floor
legend filming looking at this kan how
could it was that one from lee site of
the boy mind
every day i hope protexion knows diplomats
development worker  a conflict
into peace and flat into hoop en he
hoop de long day a nice can be this
gang and boys will find a way of
living together we dat finance en top
fashion wat en tale of the dead dead b
chance
who wants her to make ideals  and you in
many you nothing to me in the waist and
lifted the wreath
oosteind forma vader
good right to shoot and actions will
that be
assistant for me men and women
hula prepaid devices home for ls
falling world for everything
east end for the soldier
hoes of  the pass healing read and they
stone point in july tough leak
people was the couple your rocket to their
mission in afghanistan
ladies and gentle
and tilde the chance to weekend ow was the can
a lot how all three d  e pièces tablet
i do not can
free of charge it takes hardwork of too
behind the
sight intakes does he quipment and well trains
that i did this soldiers and hope you
will support the efforts of all
forces
up to 2 seats like this young captain
and provider  there i was too thin is that the
bug in my father was giving hope you
will support office or just one day a
modern
because i can ham and when your bet and
not to the claire dave model long
without long for you and who  ken
hot latin daan he hope you will respect
but socials de soldier
with this can be cause she wants a
better world league she makes an active
contribution to a better world
just makes everything to this d thank you
very much
[Applause]